hi there today we're looking at the
impute er sequence modelling via
imputation and dynamic programming by
William Chan chip 1 sorry Geoffrey
Hinton muhammad nur Uzi and Navdeep
Jaitley so this is a model to perform
sequence to sequence tasks now sequence
sequence tasks are very very common in
NLP but in this case it's kind of a
subset of sequence to sequence tasks so
a classic sequence the sequence task is
a machine translation here for example
the sentence I like you if you want to
translate it to German sorry you if you
want to translate it to German that
would become a mark day and you see that
the input is the sequence right and the
output is a sequence now the impure
deals with very special kind of sequence
the sequence tasks namely it deals with
sequence to sequence tasks that where
there is a monotonic alignment so you
see that this is given here the first
word is corresponding to the first word
here the second to the second and the
third to the third this is not always
the case in machine translation you know
different languages have different
sentence structures so for example in
French this would be your dam and you
can see that the first word is still the
first word however the third word has
become the second that you end a verb it
goes to the end so the impure would not
be able to deal with this task very well
a different task where the in pewter
would be useful for would be something
like speech recognition so if someone
were to speak the words I like you and
you would measure the waveform of that
it would look something like I like you
right so if you have this waveform let's
actually make some chunk samples out of
this let's say
this is a sample right here and here is
a break here and here right so we have
five samples on the bottom right and you
can see pretty easily that this sample
here this is the eye and then this is
silence this is the like this is silence
and this is the you so the impure deals
with these kind of sequence to sequence
a square first of all there is a
monotonic alignment very monotonic
alignment and second of all this is an
engineering constraint where the length
of the input sequence X is larger or
equal to the length of the input
sequence Y and you'll you'll see why
mainly because we rely on being able to
compute this alignment here the
alignment of input samples to output
samples right you can see that the
monotonic alignment is actually given
fairly well in speech recognition
because if something is later and down
here it is also later in the sequence up
here that is a monotonic alignment and
also usually we have more wave samples
it then we have words in the output
sequence so that would be a task for the
in pewter now let's think about how we
would do something like this so let's
put X at the top here and we said X has
5 tokens in it and let's put Y at the at
the bottom right Y actually has 3 tokens
right so this here is um I like you this
is the wave form right and we want that
I like you at the bottom so what could
we do all right first of all what the
impure does is it represents I like you
not as this form right here but as a
form where you have same length as X
divided into the same amount of things
and then it does the following
so for this this is an example right
this is how it would represent Y right
it would say I have as many chunks on
the top as on the bottom I know this
chunk here corresponds to this token
then this here to this and this here to
this and then these are these
intermediate ones right so you can see
these correspond to those these these
are silence right here now it doesn't
always need to be that there is always
one token danda silence then the token
than a silence the task of the impute is
actually to see whether this is more
likely than for example I like and then
silence silence and then you write so
the task of the impute is to distinguish
these two from each other and then of
course also produce the actual tokens
now if you think about how would you go
about taking X and producing something
like Y so this is y let's call it tilde
this is the actual Y right but you can
see that this here is a deterministic
function in one way it's actually not a
deterministic function in the other way
and that becomes interesting when you
have to compute your loss for this but
how would we go about doing this right
what we could do is we could just take a
big transformer burt right that's
actually draw an arrow we could just
take Bert and wicket simply so in in
Bert you have in if you if you construct
it correctly you have as many inputs
tokens as output tokens so what we could
simply say is for each of the outputs
that we get we simply make this as a
softmax classifier over our vocabulary
with the silence being one special token
and we simply
classify each of the outputs into this
vocabulary this would be one step right
so we could do one step Burt
bang-bang input two output and there is
more they're more sophisticated
approaches to doing this in one step
like CTC but ultimately we can just do
one step but then you'd have the same
problem like for example Excel that if
you haven't seen my excel net video I
recommend it that they exactly take the
problem if you do this right then at the
moment where you decode the word like
you have no idea that there is an eye
over here all you know is the the vector
you have here that you sample the eye
from right but this could be a
distribution where I is pretty high but
some other word is also pretty high so
this process over here that samples the
word like has no idea which of the two
here you actually would sample so it
cannot condition on it so it is the the
assumption here is that the sampling of
the word like is independent of the
sampling of the word I and of course
that's not the case the you need to know
what word is there if you want to sample
the word like otherwise you can end up
with some very confusing sentences so
this one-step process is pretty quick
but it has the drawback that there are
these conditional independence
assumptions and again I invite you to
watch the excel net video if you want to
dive more into this problem the second
thing we can do is we could just decode
one after another
right so we could say all right I'll
make sorry I'll make my five slots here
and I just leave them empty for now and
I'm just going to decode the one that I
am most sure about and let's say the the
speech at the back here is very clear
and you say ow that I'm I know this is a
you right so I'm gonna fill in you right
here
right and make this alignment that this
goes here this is the you I still don't
know what the others are but now what I
I they do a second step and in the
second step I get as an input not only
the original input like this this thing
here but I also get the fact that I
already decoded the word you two here
right in this step so now I say given
that I already decoded the word you
which one am I now most sure about and
um might be most sure about to say ah
I'm most sure about this now being an
eye because there's a you at the end and
this kind of sounds like an eye so on I
hear right it goes to the next step and
then the next step it already has the
information that it decoded I and you
and now I would say might say ah okay
given these so probably this thing so I
hear probably the thing here the thing
right here is silence right makes the
most sense I can I hear some noise but
there's already a word after so now I'm
pretty sure that this here is a silent
token right and you go this until the
end until you're actually at this so
this here would be n step decoding this
here would be n steps of decoding which
now no longer has the problem of these
conditional independence assumptions but
of course now you have the problem you
need n steps right the in pewter does
something in the middle of this the
impute err will as you can see here it
will form this in two blocks right
blocks of size B and this is the empty
symbol here right and what it will do is
it will make a step where in each block
for each block it will conditioned on
the previous alignment and conditioned
on the input it will decode whatever it
feels it is most certain about
in each block and then it does this for
as long as there are still empty tokens
right you can see here the first block
and then in the second step it will
decode this this this and this so the
impute irken trade-off between the
conditional independence assumption of
the one step bird and the full
the N step decoding right so it will
compute this alignment and the actual
tokens at the same time in this process
so how many steps does this take this
takes now B steps and this is pretty
cool because B is the block size so this
is independent of the sequence length so
it is able to compute this alignment and
output in a constant number of steps
right so you're by modulating this B
you're now able to trade off speed
versus let's say performance in the in
pewter and this is pretty cool so I
think actually I think the bigger point
to understand here is how to actually
use the assumption that there is a
monotonic alignment right because if
there is a monotonic alignment and if
this thing is given here then you can do
this you can do this representation
right here with the silenced tokens and
that allows you to basically represent
the output in a form that is of the same
length as the input and do this kind of
token by token decoding while still
allowing you to have variable lengths
output as long as they're smaller in
length than the input so that's pretty
cool and then the the next pretty cool
thing is the fact that they do this in
blocks now of course
my issue with this so this is how the
system works my issue with this is how
the system is trained so if you think
about how you train this you must train
this first of all the loss function
right has to revert this and how they do
it is they marginalize you see this down
here you want to marginalize over all
the possible alignments right here and
so this is how you train you sample an
alignment from the alignment policy and
this alignment policy is I think they
have some heuristics of how they
construct the alignments during during
training or you have experts actually
giving you this alignment I think they
use in the speech recognition they use
something like CTC to give you the
alignments from the alignment policy and
then you have a masking policy and I
think they also they just do random
masking and then they use that for
training and then they marginalize over
the alignments this I'm pretty sure is
not the same distribution as the
decoding procedure I just described
right so the decoding procedure if you
do this in B steps right that means each
of the step is dependent on the step
before so that means the distribution of
whatever you whatever the in pewter sees
is actually dependent on itself while
these people are proposing a training
framework where you have here you have a
heuristic in order to come up with the
training sample alignments and here you
have a random I think I ran the masking
policy that comes up with the with
we're the empty tokens are so this is
not the same distribution and then also
it marginalizes overall compatible
alignments which I'm I'm pretty sure
this is not the same distribution this
is not the correct lost distribution
they have some math to show that in
expectation it's the same but yeah this
is this is over there over there role in
policy and role and XOR and and
marginalization this I don't want to go
too deep into this I've given it some
thought but it will make this video too
long and boring if I actually go into
the details here suffice to say I invite
you to look at the lost computation and
ask yourself if you think that is the
correct way to produce the data set for
training given how you do the inference
later the architecture of the in pewter
is actually pretty similar to hurt in
that first of all well okay you're
dealing with audio in the input so
you're going to have some convolutional
network here and you also need to take
as an input the prior alignment that
you've already produced right so this
you embed and but then you simply do an
attention network a transformer which
will which is pretty close to to the
earth example we've made and so I mean
they stress that that their that their
loss is actually a lower bound on the
loss so I shouldn't be I shouldn't be
too hard when I say it's not the correct
distribution they do minimize something
some loss that actually makes sense but
yeah I just mainly wanted to go over the
over the how the in pewter works and how
it is structured and I think it's pretty
cool and it lends itself very well to
these tasks
and most of all I like the fact that it
exploits the these assumptions here so
not all tasks fit these assumptions but
if a task does fit the assumption then I
think it should be you know it should be
fairly obvious that one should exploit
that in order to perform better all
right that was it for me thanks